we're talking with Bethany in Tennessee
she's on her in-laws property living in
their rental house their old family home
and they come over and tell her how to
cook and how to clean she didn't like
that she's getting angry about it and
her husband's taking a job as a security
guard because he's no longer in the
police academy and so they're stuck
there for two and a half years in her
mind and that a fair summary what you
told us yeah okay how old are you I'm 22
and my husband is 26 how long you been
married two years
where's your family my family is just 30
minutes into the country side so they're
not that far no not really
okay I thought you moved from Minnesota
or something the way you're talking no
no do you have little ones in the house
I have a 16 month old daughter hmm so
here's a couple of thoughts I had during
the break and let me know if this
resonates with you first and foremost
you are 22 you're relatively new to
marriage and you got a little one
nothing in your life is gonna feel
stable
nothing's gonna feel like you think it's
supposed to or the picture you had in
your head of when you get married and
you've got a new baby it all feels
Messier and clunkier and wonk here than
it is the stages are pain in the butt
it's just it's awful and it's beautiful
and it's wonderful and it's a wreck
yeah in the butt and you are living in
somebody else's house who because you're
living in somebody else's house by
default they get a vote into how their
house looks and and then they're gonna
take advantage of that of that vote and
they're gonna dump that into you how
you're raising their grandkid and what
your decor looks like and how you're
cooking all things they shouldn't speak
into but because you live in their house
they're gonna feel entitled to do that
and then you mentioned something earlier
about your husband having a part-time
job there's a lot I come from the home
of a police officer there's a lot of
ways into the academy a lot of academies
across the country are starving for good
applicants and
so it made me that working part-time as
a security guard is not the best thing
for you guys right now because there's
gonna be a cost more than the dollar
amount go ahead
he's actually working full-time well not
my point is he may need them go make
more money and he may need to do
something that in his head is gonna be
different but it still gonna get him to
the police academy and the thing that
the most concerning thing is you already
feeling this baggage of anger resentment
and so you've probably heard this I'm
gonna all repeat this a hundred times
over but all resentment is is like
poisoning yourself and hoping somebody
else is gonna die and you are carrying
around bricks all day that do nothing
but weight you down and so what I'm
gonna suggest to you is to number one
get with somebody whether it's a friend
someone who's older and wiser and who's
been married and who's got kids and
who's been through this road before
ahead of you sit down with him and talk
to him and they can give you some wisdom
on how to put some of these bricks down
and if it's heavier than that then get
with a professional find somebody and
then sit down and talk values and talk
long term and short term with your
husband and I know sometimes guys get a
plan in their head and this is the way
this is going to be this way it's going
to be but if you're hurting to the point
that you sound like you're hurting you
need to have a values conversation with
your husband because I know that she
that the rent is cheap I've had great
opportunities where rent is cheap that
costs me part of my soul on the back end
and it's just not worth it so here's the
deal um this is just an old guy talking
dr. Jones a professional okay move you
need to move and the reason you need to
move is your husband needs to make a
choice at this stage of his marriage
between his mommy and his wife you need
to move and right now his mommy is way
too much in this picture and so you need
to move and that's your hut that's a
good thing for your husband to do in his
character in his manhood to make a
choice and say I still love my mommy
she'll always be my mommy and her truck
chip cookies may always be better than
yours but she's not my wife and she's
not between us and that's exactly what's
going on here is he is allowing this
because it doesn't feel weird to him
that she's bossy because she's his mommy
and you need to move that's all God
talking did I mess up I'm up
no that's a that's a that's a more
direct line than my psychobabble so I
like to make loop-de-loops and people
feel good so yeah you got there quick
I got I'm just saying I mean hey there's
sometimes a clubs better than a hug so
yeah the deal is it's not we can't live
here because I value my relationship
with my wife so much right that we can't
live here that's a manhood statement
right and it's not going to get better
it's gonna get worse you cannot teach
this woman boundaries you're going to
have to give some distance that's right
because this chick is used to Boston air
by around hmm I'm Hawkins I know her no
because there's a little bit of her
inside of me all right I got grown kids
and thank goodness we've got fairly
healthy boundaries right in the Ramsey
family so it's not unusual for one of my
kids spouses to say we're not coming to
Lake House this weekend we need some
space we don't all have to be on top of
each other every weekend at the lake
house that's this coming weekend by the
way so and that's cool and I got to get
cool with that since I was just Paula
because it's real comfortable for my
kids and me to all be in there together
but it's the outlaws it's harder for
them to be all piled on top of each
other
relationally and go you know that kids
misbehaving and that ones doing that and
somebody didn't clean the sink and you
know all that crap that goes on that you
give some by the side I right yep
and that happens in any receptive
relationships and it takes a lot of work
to keep those healthy boundaries inside
of every player and mama ain't doing any
work in this story that's right this is
doing no work at this I have to work at
it that's right that's why I know her
okay so so we have the chance to change
America right now Dave we've spoken into
the young couple and I'll pretend on
them that they've got to circle up look
at you there I make some hard decisions
make some hard boundary calls right now
then they're gonna have to get on the
phone and they're gonna have to say
we're not coming to the lake house this
weekend they're got the Ellen phone and
say we're moving so as the recipient of
that call what's the first thing that
goes through your heart and what do you
tell the millions of parents who are
still living vicariously through their
25 or 35 year old kids across the
country when they say I can't come to
the lake house this weekend or worse or
we're gonna move out we're gonna move
out of your realm or honestly we're not
coming because we don't want to yeah
what do you tell that that group of
adults in your age bracket well I mean
as far as that individual reaction okay
the first thing that happens inside of
you doesn't hurt your feelings right and
you just need to think that what it's
fair I would like to have all my kids
this weekend and so there's a little bit
but then you have to go oh wait a minute
hey I'm not a freakin four-year-old I
have to actually you know I don't get to
react to every little feeling that I
have I actually have a longer-term goal
with a high quality relationship which
involves letting them have their dignity
to make their own decisions and you've
trained them for years to do that
accomplished and then I'm now shocked
that they're doing that right you know
so but that's exactly what it happens
you know you think about it when your
friend just says when you're freeeeee
instance we're not coming to dinner okay
and you know what happens is you go well
why not right
that's what happens to anybody there's a
little tiny piece of rejection and if
you if you get all four-year-old ish
about it every time you do that then you
hurt the dignity of the long-term
relationship because you're not
respecting that other person to be an
entity that's right there's somebody
that's that is an extension of my
self-esteem or someone is an extension
of my well-being right Daniel and
Allison about married two years houses
parents are in Kansas City they're
wonderful people she's a wonderful girl
they're incredible they're incredible
but that you know young couples were
married two years mmm I got to love them
enough to give them a little room that's
right they're newlyweds still thank
have a little room and they David no I
would just keep them right they've got
to figure out how to together have joint
courage to say we're not coming to
Thanksgiving this year we're gonna do
Christmas like this and that we're gonna
do Thanksgiving you next year this year
and then I have to go bite my little
quivering little lip and you know be a
grown-up because that I didn't want to
be that parent that was always a jerk
about Thanksgiving
you know and so I'm getting ready to pay
me just for just a second there I was
getting ready to be and I got on no
that's not it
I love the long-term more than I like
the short-term thing here solving
America's problems David Ramsey if you
can solve Thanksgiving you've done it
man